>> Chris: WELL, NOW IT'S TIME TO
PLAY TOYS 'R' UPSETTING.
TOYS 'R' UPSETTING.
TODAY IS BARBIE DAY,
CELEBRATING THE 1959 DEBUT
OF THE ICONIC CLASSIC BEAUTY
WITH THE IMPOSSIBLY HIGH
PHYSICAL STANDARD.
SINCE THEN THE ONLY THINGS
THAT'S GROWN MORE THAN THE
TOY BUSINESS HAS BEEN THE
BOOTLEG TOY BUSINESS.
PLAYBOY.COM TOOK ILL-ADVISED
TIME AWAY FROM SHOWING
BOOBIES TO COMPILE TRULY A I
MAGAZINE BLACK MARKET ACTION
FIGURES.
COMEDIANS, I WILL SHOW YOU
BOOTLEG TOYS. FOR 250 POINTS
GIVE A LINE FOR THE SATURDAY
MORNING COMMERCIAL FOR THESE
KNOCKOFFS.
THESE COMPLETELY AUTHENTIC
NINJA TORTOISES.
THEY'RE DIFFERENT, YOUR
HONOR, COME ON.
>> I THINK THE CATCHPHRASE
WAS, "ZEROES IN A HALF-SHELL.
TORTOISE POWER."
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
>> AND THEN THE SEQUEL TO THE
MOVIE, "SECRET OF THE SPOOGE."
>> Chris: I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS
FOR THE FIRST PART.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Chris: I SHOULD TAKE THEM
AWAY FOR THE SECOND ONE.
>> I KNEW EXACTLY WHAT YOU
WERE DOING.
>> Chris: HERE WE GO.
I WILL TAKE THE POINTS AWAY.
>> THAT WAS SMOOTH.
>> I LIKE THIS.
>> Chris: YOU KNOW YOU WHAT GOT
TO DO TO GET THOSE BACK.
>> PORCH DICK.
>> Chris: YEAH! A HUNDRED POINTS
FOR MAMRIE.
>> HEY.
>> WHAT?
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, I CAN'T
STAY MAD AT YOU.
HERE IS YOUR 250 POINTS BACK
BACK.
>> YAY!
>> Chris: MAMRIE.
>> CLEANING UP THE MEAN
STREETS OF GALLAPGOS.
>> Chris: YES, PONTS.
I LOVE IT.
>> THAT WAS-- THAT WAS
CLEVER.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, THIS HALF
ASS ATTEMPT AT BUSTING GHOSTS.
WHAT IS THAT?
(LAUGHTER)
>> WHAT?
>> Chris: I AM NOT FRIGHTENED BY
A SPOOK.
YASSIR.
>> A SPOOK-CHASERS, ONLY
SOLD IN THE SOUTH.
>> Chris: OH, [BLEEP]. OH, MAN.
(APPLAUSE)
>> SPOOK CHASERS!
WHO WILL YOU TELEPHONE?
SPOOK CHASERS!
>> WHO ARE YOU GO STOCK PAGE?
>> Chris: IF THERE IS A THING
THAT IS STRANGE, IF YOUR HOUSE
IS NEAR YOU.
WHO WILL YOU TELEPHONE,
SPOOK CHASERS!
(APPLAUSE)
JONAH RAY.
>> OH, IS IT TIME FOR ME?
>> Chris: YEAH.
>> SPOOK CHASER, WE WENT
WITH THE FIRST NAME WE COULD
THINK OF THAT WAS PROBABLY A
REAL BAD IDEA.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
>> IT WASN'T FUNNY 50
[BLEEP] MINUTES AGO.
(APPLAUSE)
I HAVE TO DO MY JOKE AFTER THE
APPLAUSE BREAK OF YOUR PARODY
SONG.
>> I'M SORRY, I'M TOO FUNNY FOR
YOU TO FOLLOW, JONAH.
(APPLAUSE)
>> IF I HAD ANOTHER 20 YEARS ON
THIS EARTH, I WOULD BE AS FUNNY
AS YOU?
>> Chris: OH, YOU SON OF A
BITCH.
HOW DARE YOU!
HOW [BLEEP]ING DARE YOU!
NEXT ONE, THIS BLOATED SHREK.
WHAT IS THIS.
WHAT IS THAT?
SHREK 2?
SHREK SMASH.
MAMES.
>> MAY CAUSE EXCESSIVE
BULLYING.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JONAH.
>> YOU CAN FIT UP TO FIVE
LUNCHABLES, YOU FAT POOR
KID.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS FOR JONAH.
JONAH.
>> WHAT?
>> Chris: WERE YOU THAT LITTLE
FAT POOR KID?
>> I WAS THAT LITTLE FAT
POOR KID!
>> Chris: YELLING AT YOURSELF.
FINALLY THIS MAY NOT BE A
KNOCKOFF BUT IT IS CERTAIN
TO COMPLETELY MIND-[BLEEP]
YOUR CHILD --
DOGS!
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> Chris: RUFF, RUFF.
LOOK AT THE SIZE OF MY
EGGS, RUFF, RUFF.
YASSIR.
>> STEVIE WONDER PRESENTS:
DOGS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
AMAZING.